ていた
yeah
うん
お久しぶりです最近気づいたんですけどこたつ打ったから福江がないんですよねなんで
もこのなんかポップ
こういう感じで取ります机の上に三脚をたいってテレパスとえっと
カメラ置いている状況なんでもうこれで固定にするかもしれないですよね時にこんな
感じであるね
しばらく
いきましょう
あん
ん
塩酸
うわっ
ファー生産が円札とコンビニのバイト増えたんでちょっと
また商品レビューしたい
あれが出て潤担ねー
はいパピコのバニラ close
はいどうですか
ってかまずまずですよ
あのパピコつでもともとなんか
チョコしかないですねあそこって感がコーヒーみたいなありがとうござんパリ好きじゃ
ないんですよコーヒー食べれ何吸っ
いい
僕とかなんかあんまり相手って言ったバイアスが好きじゃないんで
これをもうデフォルトで準備しておいて欲しかったですね
おっ
あ
あああれだ
mac の請求さない方のシェイクなるがもうすぐがます物の請求の味がしますもう
差し指の食べたことあるちょっと高めだからきっと貴族の人とか食べしか食べれないと
思うんですけどもすんのシェイクの味がしますから
美味しいですね
ね新学期のラッシュなスタートがちょっと一段落して3年生だっていろいろあったん
ですけど
ちょっとちょっと一段落したんで動画の頻度を上げてきたかなかなーって思いますで何
かねちょっと今年度のね今年度はちょっと僕進化しますよ
ビデオブログ的な感じで移行したいと思ってるんで
けどちょっといろいろ試してみます彼の動画でも別バナー
払ってもらえることだと思ってるんでねん
とゆーわけねー
あたら青パックはもうすぐの味がしますソースも酢の味がされますもしロス by
ガードは正規祝ねっとか食べてみたらいいと思う
おっ
ああああああ